In order for strings to be localized,
it helps to move all
strings into strings.xml.
Any string that is hard
coded cannot be translated
without modifying the compiled code.
In the strings.xml file, you
will want to comment thoroughly in order
to provide the context for the string.
This will result in higher
quality translations.
You may want to include information
such as, what is this string for,
when is it presented to the user,
where is this in the layout?
For example, translations are less
flexible for a button than a text box.
You can also specify strings that
should not be translated simply with
a placeholder tag.
Finally, there are a variety of system
provided formats for dates, times,
numbers, and currencies.
So take advantage of our
utils such as date format for
dates, decimal format and string
format for numbers and currency, and
phone number utils for phone numbers to
simplify formatting across your locals.